The joe rogan experience.
That was,
by the way,
it was in a six and a half minute workout.
Oh,
here comes Brian.
You must know where online now.
Six and a half.
Do this online lifting.
All right.
Hey little fella.
Oops.
Here we go.
Hey little fella.
We're on the air right now.
Well,
you're sleeping.
How dare you.
I'm,
I'm in a panic because I can't get,
I guess it doesn't matter,
but I can't get that dissolve thing to work where you can't see the text at the
bottom of the screen.
Yeah.
You know how you can make the tax fade out.
How do I do that?
Should I sing background music while he did his?
Yeah,
his name Ma'am.
Okay,
and right click on a scene that you're on.
Okay.
To
edit shot.
It's a really nice contrast.
It's got a wide face,
Exxon,
it lod phase,
lag chairs,
so on and costly.
I don't see that.
That's where it's confusing.
She's too,
he's no,
I have the,
it's just you.
I was trying to put Brian's name up because it's your name on it.
He's got shoulders for days and a really wide
shoulders.
So what should I do?
The last one is Christina [inaudible] and it's got like a names on it.
Oh,
the last thing on the far right.
Nia.
That one's just me now
and now that's just Brian.
Oh,
I could go back and forth from Brian to me.
be sexy.
Yes.
Do you like my background?
[inaudible] sound on those.
Oh,
okay.
So I should stick with what I'm on.
Thank you for sharing with us in this technical break.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I'm going to keep singing the song about Joe Rogan.
He's got a,
Whoa,
okay,
well we'll have to deal with this,
but on the,
so the,
um,
the text,
there's no way to get rid of that text on the screen.
Simple.
He's got a wife and he's really flexible.
His name is Joe Rogan.
He's got a watch face and neck wad face on a short neck.
See,
I don't see that though.
When I'm trying to do that.
I can't,
it's not letting me do that means he can absorb punches really well.
Should have been a fighter buddies,
ladies and gentlemen home.
This is boring as fuck.
I'm sure I'm singing now.
That shows logic,
camera logic,
camera built in eyesight.
Those are the options.
I'm singing background music.
Did builtin input.
Uh,
it shouldn't be anything on,
it should have been a gymnast.
He should have been in,
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing,
dude.
We're going to have to have you.
Uh,
this is a good job.
Security for you.
The whole of the whole show goes to shit without red band.
Okay.
All right.
Well now for some reason it says Eddie Bravo.
I must have changed it.
I don't mind being Eddie Bravo.
Okay.
This is Eddie Bravo.
Now they used to,
well,
we'll just give him plugs to our friends.
I'll be at the American that comedy.
Oh yeah.
Let me check.
Was Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday.
Everybody,
the American comedy and make sure that you move it close Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday.
I should turn up my volume.
Are you,
what is he talking about?
Go,
I'm just getting,
I'm just,
uh,
I'm talking to Brian Cowen.
He's talking on the podcast.
The same songs about you name is gill rogue and he's got a lot better.
We're just trying to see if this thing is actually online.
It's kind of long eye lashes and he's really flexible.
He can do impressions.
Nobody knows that.
Here's Joe Rural Gum is really muscular.
Got a wide face,
wide face,
Santa Short neck,
which means he can take a punch to his fucking knows better than you can.
His name was Joe Rogan.
Joe.
Oh God.
John,
wrong.
Hang on.
I'm trying to come up with other words.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
It's working.
All right,
I'll see you all tomorrow,
Jamie.
Kilstein later.
Bye.
So,
uh,
we'll have that soon.
All right.
And I'm,
and I'm going to record the,
uh,
the Joe Rogan a soundtrack to it in the back
to all roll gum.
What's the sound?
Well,
this is the podcast starting out.
You use the code name Brogan,
get 10% off any and all supplements at [inaudible] dot com including the hemp
force and the kettle bells in the battle ropes.
However we were selling those bitches as cheap as we can.
Battle ropes is the cheapest you can find on the Internet and battle ropes or in
another awesome caveman style.
Manly motherfucking workout.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com o.
N.
N I t hit it.
I was just gonna say,
I think it wasn't the same.
What do you do when you're single Joe Rogan's show he got shot.
You got to get Deb down three pillars.
I don't have the whole song,
but I got
told role gum.
He is your friend Joe row.
Come.
He is the man until Rogan.
He's got the best damn podcast in the land.
He's got a thick short neck and a wad face and very expressive.
Very expressive eyes.
He's going go home moms.
Sure.
Lanks and um,
hi Todd.
How son of borough snakes ball loopback a payroll.
The snakes full Rebecca at the maximum of fat that his lower extremities when
they are more at home on a mew who I know who,
who's Joe Rogan?
He's your friend and Joe Rogan is the ma'am.
He's so Rogan.
He's got the best damn podcast.
Thank you very much.
Help you and it,
that's how I had had that.
It's emotional.
It's all,
I can't you guys,
maybe I'll add some more verses,
but that's all I've got for now.
I was a Schomburg nursing,
that stupid song in the shower.
You sing that song.
I was like,
yeah.
I woke up morning,
I was like,
I'm bored.
And I was like,
in Joel's room girl.
He goes,
mom name was Joe Rogan,
and I started breaking down your body.
You might have like the worst sense of beat and rhythm ever.
I'll do it.
I'm the terrible thing you're talking about.
I'm not have no words.
I am the police.
How many police put that to music so I can,
so I can just revel in,
play it on a loop in my car.
Okay.